new signs around RAF Croton are a
reminder of what side of the road
drivers should be on but dash cam
footage filmed on Friday shows a car
with diplomatic plates from the US air
base on the wrong side of this country
lane nearby police say one of their own
vehicles was also struck by a driver
from the station in October the latest
incidents were put to the prime minister
for certainly raising all those issues
and we're continuing to work for the
justice nineteen-year-old Harry Dunne
was killed in a collision with American
answer coulis in August she just left
RAF Croton and admitted driving on the
wrong side of the road
she claimed diplomatic immunity and left
the country Harry's family were
unimpressed by the Prime Minister's
comment we don't need sound bites what
we need is a plan and a review and then
you know what are we going to do to make
everybody safe for both the American
people who work here and the residents
around for those living in surrounding
villages the latest incidents have been
unsettling with the signs and not being
outside the base to prompt them to drive
the correct side and that's still not I
just think I don't know I think it's
very unnerving that it is still
happening you think that it's an
isolated incident with Harley also now
if is being recorded and it's
reoccurring why are these people being
trained to drive on the right side of
the road first of all you know if you
have this problem that now after such a
big instance be made of it and coming
from the same base again I mean it just
feels like you're fighting against
something that they just don't care they
just it just I feel that they're not
taking the time to care about what's
happened and how devastating this has
been in our area the Foreign Office has
the latest reports disturbing and both
the chief constable for Northamptonshire
and the local MP Andrea led some are
demanding urgent meetings with the base
commander here one suggestion has been
driving tests for new arrivals to the
base but so far the US Embassy has not
commented on the recent incidents all
said whether the meetings will take
place these are doubts Sky News
Northamptonshire